I stand here truly humbled that I've
been allowed to be one of your musical
representatives and that you would
choose to still dishonor upon me during
what has been a emotional and difficult
time for my family
family has always come first for Michael
Buble and as he proudly accepted his
Governor General honor you could tell he
was holding back tears my entire life
has been inspired by how my family has
made me feel my wife my children my
parents my sisters sometimes I love you
just isn't enough because what I do is
so much more his wife Luisana has been
with him every step of the way posing
with a huge smile and instagramming this
pic with the hashtag proud wife during
last night's ceremony ruth be performed
but it was a huge surprise of joan jett
taking the stage with honoree Michael J
Fox playing guitar that had everyone on
their feet
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
terms of early impulses the first to
come to mind are none other than
Friendly Giant mr. Bress I can't tell
you how humble this tremendous honor
makes a huge Canadian icon like myself
you Martin Short kept the last going
both on stage and off yeah so tell me
where will you what will you wear this
with after this suit because now you're
wearing it with a beautiful student but
when when you're at home what are you
going to be wearing with the cottage
show v mania speedo what a great night
to be honoring your dear friend yes my
dear friend Wow we go back a long way 40
44 years 46 years maybe so many Canadian
performers have been inspired and gone
on to emulate them so you know now this
is a paltry reward here have a medal no
that's nice also announced today the 99
honorees of this year's Order of Canada
that includes stars Catherine O'Hara
Mike Myers and Jeopardy's Alex Trebek
it's a special honor it's a recognition
we've done a good job in our careers we
haven't messed up we have not brought
dishonor to Canadians or to Canada and
we are highly regarded